apologies for my prolonged absence I've
been dealing over the last few weeks
with my somewhat shaky current health it
seems probable that I could use arrest
if I had the opportunity and I knew how
I should probably be having a rest right
now but be that as it may I have
prepared this letter presumptuously to
the world or at least to that corner of
it with which I can communicate here at
the dawn of the new year in these
perilous times although I usually speak
extemporaneously that takes a level of
capacity that I cannot quite currently
manifest so I'm going to read instead
it's also a careful argument I hope and
it required the editing for which only
the written word can suffice dear world
On January 16th I'm going to talk with
Sam Harris on his podcast waking up with
sam Harris dr. Harris is one of the
so-called New Atheists
of which there are four like the other
three Christopher Hitchens Dan Dennett
and Richard Dawkins who by the way I
always wanted particularly to debate dr.
Harris is a smart guy and I'm certainly
not complaining that I will encounter
him instead of Dawkins so I'm preparing
my arguments carefully although I have
been doing so for years the specific
ideas i'm going to share with you today
were obsessing me from the moment I woke
up somewhat fitfully this morning so I
dictated them to my son and then edited
them with his help the central problem
of human beings isn't religion as the
New Atheists insist it's tribalism we
know this in part because chimps our
closest biological can go to war and
they're not religious although they are
tribal tribalism also has a central
problem and it's not competition despite
the tendency of competition to produce
at least temporarily
the winners and losers the problem of
tribalism is cooperation because
cooperation is what allows us to exist
is bounded groups a group by definition
is a collective cooperatively aiming at
something it can't be aimed at nothing
because nothing cannot unite it only
divides thus attacks on collective
purpose because of its tendency to
produce tribalism merely divide the
politics of identity which emerge when
the central purpose is criticized to
destructively inevitably produce the
situation described in the story of the
Tower of Babel
everyone fragments into primitive tribes
and speaks their own mutually
incomprehensible language one
alternative to fragmentation is of
course Union under a banner a collective
ideal cause or purpose
the problem with uniting under a banner
as the post modernists who push identity
politics rightly point out is that to
value something means simultaneously to
devalue other things thus to value is an
exclusionary process but the alternative
is valueless nough sequinned to nihilism
a nihilism does not produce freedom from
exclusion it just makes everyone
excluded and that's an intolerable state
directionless uncertain chaotic and
angst-ridden
when such uncertainty reaches a critical
level the counter response appears first
the unconscious and then the
collectively expressed demand for a
leader possessed by the spirit of
totalitarian certainty who promises
above all to restore order
thus a society without a unifying
principle oscillates unmoored between
nihilism and totalitarianism human
beings have been wrestling with this
problem since the beginning of
civilization when our capacity to form
large groups for all its advantages all
started to pose a new threat that of the
hyper domination of the state collective
or purpose but without the state there's
just fragmentation into smaller groups
the group itself cannot be done away
with because for better or worse
human beings are social animals not
loners like sharks or Tigers we're team
players but being on one team means not
being on others this means that any
given team sidelines marginalizes and
alienates those who cannot play their
game as well as conflicting with other
teams in the West starting in the Middle
East thousands of years ago a new idea
began to emerge evolve is not too strong
a word in the collective imagination
you might following darkens consider
this a meme although this is far too
weak a word this idea whose development
can be traced back through Egypt to
Mesopotamia before disappearing into
unwritten history is that of the divine
individual this eons old work of the
imagination is a dramatic presentation
of an emergent idea which is the
solution to how to organize social being
without falling prey to nihilistic
divisive Nisour deceitful totalitarian
certainty the group must unite but under
the banner of the individual the
individual is the source of the new
wisdom that updates the antiquated
nihilistic or totalitarian d'etre TISS
and glory of the past for better or for
worse that idea reaches its Apogee in
Christianity the divine individual is
masculine because the feminine is not
individual the divine feminine is
instead mother and child however it is a
hallmark of Christian supposition that
the redemption of both men and women
comes through the masculine and that's
because the masculine is the individual
to central realization
expressed dramatically and symbolically
is that the subordination of the group
to the ideal of the divine individual is
the answer to the paradox of nihilism
and totalitarianism the divine
individual is the man that every man
admires and a man whom all women want
their men to be the divine individual is
the ideal from which deviations are
punished by the group with contempt and
disgrace and fidelity to which is
rewarded by the group with attention and
honor the divine individual is not the
winner of any individual game but the
player who plays fairly and is therefore
continually invited to play the divine
individual is the builder maintainer and
expander of the state he who boldly goes
where no man has gone before and someone
who eternally watches over the widows
and the children his power of direct and
honest communication is that which
identifies discusses and then resolves
the continually emergent problems of
human existence it is for this reason
that he is regarded as the savior of the
world
the primary image for women is not the
divine individual because of the heavy
burden they bear for reproduction it is
instead the divine mother and child this
is not to say that man is the divine
individual and woman is not although
such confusion is understandable given
the complexity of the problem man like
women have the divine mother and child
as an element of their personality a man
however it's in the background so to
speak as the divine individual is in the
background of the psyche for women men
by necessity play a less primary role in
the care of children this frees them to
act as individuals in a manner that up
to now has been nearly impossible for
women identification with these images
is belief in the belief is not the
statement of agreeing
with a set of facts but the willingness
to act something out to become something
to stake your life on something for men
and women alike
this means voluntary adoption of
responsibilities responsibilities for
oneself family and state it's in that
responsibility and not in rights that
meaning itself resides the meaning that
makes life bearable societies that
refuse to honor both of these elements
therefore doom their inhabitants to
purposelessness unhappiness sterility
and the aforementioned dangers of
nihilistic divisiveness and deceitful
oppressive totalitarian certainty the
meaning and responsibility is the
necessary meaning in life which can
serve as a counterbalance to it's
terrible fragility and tenuousness
people must unite under the banner not
of their group and not of nothingness
but of the individual this is a
brilliant and intrinsically paradoxical
solution to the problems of nihilistic
nothingness and too rigid group identity
alike it's the consciousness of the
individual which transforms the chaos of
potential into habitable cosmos as the
greatest origin stories repeatedly
insist it is that same consciousness
which stands up rebellious and
revelatory to break down the
pathological and too rigid order of that
cosmos when it has become old infirm
willfully blind and corrupt it is that
consciousness which is the image of God
it dwells within every embodied human
form the fact of its existence is the
reason that the law of the land itself
must be bound by ultimate respect for
the individual regardless of his or her
sins and crimes it is that consciousness
not the objective material substrate of
being which should be regarded as the
ultimate reality there's no self-evident
reason why dead matter should be given
ontological primacy over living spirit
although doing so has produced a massive
increase in human technological power it
has left that power in the hands of an
increasingly disenchanted populace and
that presents a mortal danger
such power must be wielded by those who
have truly and voluntarily accepted the
responsibility of being lest it prove
fatal
the West has long been the civilized
embodiment of the idea of the divine
individual who does exactly that that's
what the voluntary lifting of the cross
of suffering symbolically represents for
all its faults which are manifold the
West has therefore served as a shining
beacon of hope to those destined to
inhabit places too chaotic or too rigid
for the human spirit to tolerate about
the West is in grave danger of losing
its way the negative consequences of
this can hardly be overstated a close
reading of 20th century history
indicates as nothing else can the
horrors that accompany loss of faith in
the idea of the individual it is only
the individual after all who suffers -
the group does not suffer
only those who compose it thus the
reality of the individual must be
regarded as primary if suffering is to
be regarded seriously without such a
regard there can be no motivation to
reduce suffering and therefore no
respite instead the production of
individual suffering can and has and
will be again rationalized it justified
for its supposed benefits for the future
and the group effective birth control
has emerged as one of the consequences
of our powerful technological
materialism this has been accompanied by
the rise of state sufficiently civilised
so that women who inhabit them can walk
the streets unaccompanied in safety we
do not yet know how to balance the
opportunities thus provided for expanded
female individuality with the eternal
necessity for a woman to serve as the
mother of the Divine individual dividing
our civilization into polarized
ideological camps of female group
identity and male group identity is
certainly not the answer we have to be
honest male and female alike about what
we really want as individuals and talk
it out we know beyond dispute the
societies whom emancipate their women
are more productive and peaceful and
that the relationship is causal thus
it's not a matter of if but how but such
impacts emancipation places a dual
burden on the now more autonomous woman
who is required to balance manifesting
the potential of her individual spirit
with the necessity of desire to bear and
rear the next generation of mankind to
live with free women
and gain the advantages of their freedom
and sophistication men must therefore
bring their shadowed psychic
identification with the divine mother
and child into the light without losing
their divine individuality in the
process they must consciously
voluntarily deliberately and
strategically accept their
responsibility for the relationship
between autonomous female companionship
support love and the responsibility of
producing that next generation this
means rejecting among other things the
misbegotten idea of casual sexual
gratification sex is either the
impulsive short-term gratification of a
domineering biological instinct or the
union of two conscious spirits taking
responsibility for what they are doing
the former is simply not commensurate
with the demands of an advanced
civilization which requires the adoption
of responsibilities above all for its
preservation maintenance and expansion
it is for this reason that the
sexualized interactions between young
men and women in universities for
example are increasingly and inevitably
falling under the harsh and tyrannical
regulation of the state in the West we
are as well shuttering our great
cathedrals those marvelous monumental
embodiments of the idea of the Divine
individual on which our civilization is
based this is no mirror practical
material matter it's a symbolic and
it'll process whose importance cannot be
overstated
without that central idea we will
dissolve and be lost it is time for each
of us to consciously realize what the
great symbolic stories of the past
insist upon that we are all sons and
waters of the Divine logos consciousness
itself bearers of its light and that we
must act in accordance with that great
central fact lest all hell break loose
this means above all to tell the truth
and to care for one another starting at
the level of the individual and
proceeding from that out to the broader
reaches of society itself the
alternative as these same stories have
always insisted is the more permanent
instantiation of the horror that we
already saw manifest in multiple forms
in the last bloody terrible century we
need to wake up individual man and woman
alike then we need to do it now each of
us must take the world on our shoulders
insofar as we're capable of that and
adopt individual responsibility for the
horrors and suffering its existence
entails in that we will find the meaning
without which life is merely the
suffering that breeds first resentment
and then the desire for vengeance and
destruction we need to take
responsibility instead of incessantly
insisting on our rights we need to
become adults instead of aged children
we need to tell the truth we need
justice and compassion conjoined not
judgment and pity which crush and devour
so in the coming year plan to make
yourself a better person fix what you
can and would fix start now
there's something right in front of you
demanding repair calling out to your
conscience
if you would only attend to it for your
corrective efforts however primitive
they may yet be start small as you
master the process you can safely and
competently expand your reach you will
then be able to fix bigger things
instead of making them worse in the
arrogance of your ignorance if you do
this there will be less pointless and
unnecessary suffering and the world for
all its shortcomings and faults will be
a better place until we can imagine
better than that
that's meaning and purpose enough Happy
New Year and best wishes to you all